is it hard to  to deal with because i'm how many baby  mamas you have  hold on  six five or six five or six you're not  sure i'm not sure  that's great i got three for one girl  and the wrist i got one  that sounds like that sounds like uh  five then three for one  or maybe six i don't know chris my math  is not good three for one girl so it's  three  so you might have six six six  uh is it hard to deal with like all of  the baby mamas  oh it used to be like you know it used  to be but  i'm not only having trouble with one  baby mama right now like i'm not  i've been having this sweet boy i ain't  gonna lie i've been having this sweet  cuz i ain't [ __ ] nothing right you  [ __ ] your baby moms that's when you have  all the [ __ ] problems and [ __ ] yeah  cause then they get emotional then they  say  when they shouldn't have to say [ __ ] so  i just  i just keep it cultural i'm in a good  position with my baby mamas i ain't  gonna lie bro